welcome to the Khan Academy the goal of
this video is to show you all the
different things that Khan Academy has
it has videos it has exercises it has an
adaptive super I guess you could call it
robot tutor thing that will guide you
through content and make sure you master
it and so let's just take each of those
one by one so many of y'all are probably
coming to the sign saying hey I have an
exam tomorrow on DNA or I didn't
understand quite what's happening in
class well they're the best thing to do
might just be go to the search bar let
me make sure you can see the search bar
to go to the search bar and you could
search for DN DNA and when you do that
you see that no your first choice right
over here is a DNA video and this is
actually the main video on DNA in which
you could start watching or if you look
to the right right over here you see
that there's all other related videos it
under heredity and genetics and then you
could start browsing from there you
could say okay let me back up a second
let me go back to just all of biology
and I can see all of the sections are
there similarly you might want to search
for something in mathematics you might
want to say oh you know I have question
about quadratics quadratics so I'm going
to search there like okay well let's see
there's something about using the
quadratic formula factoring quadratics -
well I don't know which of these is
right for me so let me just let me just
let me just go into one of these and
start getting a little bit of context
and so you see that this this what I
actually just clicked on is actually an
exercise that gets me to solve
quadratics by factoring - and I want to
I need to write my answer here if I
don't know the answer I have a bunch of
hints if this all looks like a Greek to
me
I can click on a I can click on a video
that solves a very similar problem or I
might say you know this is what I was
looking for but look I look over here
they're solving a quadratic equation by
factoring factoring quadratic equations
maybe this is what I need to learn or
maybe I'm not even thinking about this
stuff so let me just move up a level to
quadratic equations and now I can see
the whole topic here solving quadratics
by taking square roots solving
quadratics by factoring completing the
square the quadratic formula quadratic
equation graphing quadratics now in
general if you just
Brow's let me just see all the subjects
that are available on Khan Academy you
can go to this drop-down right over here
and this starts to give you a sense of
the breadth of the content on Khan
Academy
so just in math each of these is an
entire subject so K through second math
you have early you have precalculus goes
all the way up to multivariable calculus
integral calculus and if I were to kick
click on any one of these things if I
were to click on any one of these things
it's going to take me into something
called a mission so a mission it's going
to give me a set of exercises we call
this right over here the mission the
mission warm-up and based on how I
perform on these calculus questions the
system is trying to get a sense of what
I know and don't know and then it will
use that to give me guided practice so
that I can learn more and more and more
calculus eventually mastering calculus
at any point if I have difficulty
there's always videos here that will
help me understand the actual calculus
and so once I'm done with that I will go
to this dashboard and it will just tell
me about how much have I progressed in
integral calculus
what have I mastered what have I not
practiced yet what are my different
badges now if you do not want to move
immediately into this mission world and
you want to say hey well what does Khan
Academy have when it comes to calculus
in an unguided way well that's where you
go full view full list of integral
calculus content and then you will go to
this page where you see the breadth and
scope of the integral content integrals
integration techniques integration
applications sequences in series AP
calculus practice problems and if you
click there you see the different you do
the different tutorials with them
indefinite integrals as anti derivative
area under a rate function as net change
so hopefully that gives you a sense of
things and we don't just have math and
we just don't have science we have a
whole section here on computer
programming which is tons of fun where
you can write your own you can write
your own computer programs as these are
I'm losing my son's account right now
these are this is a computer program
that we wrote this right here is a
computer program that we wrote together
the other the other day it was very good
father father-son bonding time and we
have things in the arts and humanities
like history and art history which is
also very very very exciting and we have
partner content
we have partner content from the likes
of from the likes of the Museum of
Modern Art expert or iam JP Getty Museum
the British Museum so a lot of stuff
here hopefully this video gives you a
flavor of the different ways that you
can use Khan Academy